Let's go through it together.
We need to make a new environment, and the parent pointer of that new environment
should point to the environment the function was declared in.
This is tricky, and it's easy to get this wrong.
Don't use the environment we already have lying around;
use the one we got out of the function. Currently it's empty.
There is nothing in our mapping.
So our next step is to evaluate the actual arguments and make room for them.
The actual arguments may be as simple as the number 2,
or they may be complicated mathematical expressions.
We will go over each one in turn, and for that particular argument
we will evaluate it in the current environment.
Not in the function declaration environment; in the current one.
We haven't really made this new one yet.
And now we'll add to our environment.
This line was particularly tricky because it requires you to remember
what our environment really is.
It's a tuple with 2 parts: a parent pointer and a dictionary.
We want to get out the oneth part, the dictionary,
and extend it so that when it refers to the ith formal parameter,
that binds to the value of the ith actual argument.
So in our example up here with calling the function square root on 2,
the parameter name is x, the actual argument value is the number 2.
X is now bound to 2.
fparams[i]] is the variable name x,
argval is the number 2.
That's actually it for our new environment,
so now we just want to evaluate the body in that environment.
One line suffices.
Remember that much like the if-then-else statement we've seen before
with the curly braces in JavaScript, a function body may have many statements,
so we'll use our eval-stmts procedure on the body in the new environment.
This is critical. We don't want to use any of the old environments.
We need the new ones where the formal parameters are bound to the actual arguments.
And that's it.